the other thing that's interesting is
you were on Shark Tank so as a fan of
reality TV me and Sam both watched the
challenge probably the trashiest reality
show love is blind yeah we didn't it all
come out already then they just released
I'm at episode 3 of that one good show
pretty good show
have you seen it do you know the premise
it's actually pretty cool as a suit
experiment or you cut off the show like
no you don't get like eliminated
survivor style do you just edit you out
like you just not shown ever again if
you didn't propose and so what ends up
happening is it's 10 days behind a wall
you talk to this person and you're
speed-dating basically behind a wall so
you're kind of like deciding who you
like and then someone proposes through
the wall so they're like can you come
close to the wall please I'm on a knee
now and I want to you know I see to
marry me and then but the thing is that
I thought that's where the show would
end but then they like put them in the
real world together and they're like all
right you're gonna get married in 30
days and see what happens and it's
pretty interesting good job Netflix
ownership Shark Tank because tell me
about how it came about you you applied
many times one time how'd you get on
once your honor before you okay I would
say like so I we aired in November of
2017 the beginning auditions like a
nine-month process of I would say so we
applied
and by me it's like a 50 page written
application online or I tried to like
use a PDF Editor so you write this whole
thing up I write this whole thing out I
will be honest I was I was a finalist at
TechCrunch Battlefield about 16 the
producers Scout they reached out maybe
they reached out so it's kind of like if
you're thinking about American Idol
maybe whatever but you you either can
get contacted and sort of in the front
in the audition or you kind of wait line
so it's not that I had necessarily a
better chance but I did get shortcut to
the question process so filled that out
the obligation probably takes 40 hours
and then you have to sign all their
contracts and basically sign your
identity and image away and then from
there you do a voice interview with
producers you do a video interview as
well with the application that other
video interview of your pitch and then
from there the producers work with you
for about four months together like what
is your story what is your brand what is
your strategy ultimately your what I
think people don't realize human
interest story it's a human interest
story you are there to make good reality
TV but it is your decision the producers
will help you and advise you but this is
your gig and it's up to you to decide
how you want to display yourself and who
you want to be on TV but so do you still
remember do you still remember your
opening because you probably drilled it
like a thousand times I did I did and I
will tell you I thought I was like
really good and comfortable at public
speaking and then I did this I was like
okay I was really bad no I I did so I
signed or I shook on the largest deal
ever for a female entrepreneur in terms
of valuation so yeah with Lori Grenier
she is on board she's been tremendous
because of QVC or what for me it was
really at the time we had no
brick-and-mortar retail presence and I
knew that that was a priority for us to
create a product it was like actually
accessible and ubiquitous and that's
actually
in heights I've been are really gonna
move for us but I felt that she would be
invaluable in helping us to get you know
those stories yeah she really helped
with packaging and branding and making
something that's accessible when you're
trying to like sell a testing kit where
either people think it's a DNA kit right
where they have no idea what it is right
being able to differentiate bout me of
like 10 seconds to grab see I'm gonna be
ready so the deal we shook on because
there's the shake on it and then there's
the actual - for the company and
probably better for Lori and better
because why does the deal change so
normally there's like they do diligence
and they might change it probably for
their favor you're saying it better for
you guys how does it improve I wanna
make sure you project because your audio
yours what you're saying is great I want
to make sure we're getting it all
so my audio paranoia just make sure your
talk louder than you're comfortable
talking so after you shake on the deal
on the show a fair number of those deals
I think it's something like over half
never come to fruition at all and then
another quarter or so actually change
and then another quarter gets done at
the terms that I think eat shark eat
shark has a different approach so like I
they're totally you then go into their
management company right so you're going
into Mark Cuban companies or Lori or
nears companies and so it's not a I
don't know what eat sharks processes I
can say Lori's was super fair they go
through very detailed diligence on
everything but but you know what the
show actually does diligence on you they
have a venture analyst on board so they
run diligence on you before you ever pay
I I pitched I my valuation was twenty
million post-money it was a line of
credit deal at an eight percent interest
rate for five percent of the company and
was it like you know hey deal offer on
the spot or do you have this like long
pause where you like can I think and
write this down well in my case every
shark was out
I actually knew I wanted either lawyer
or mark green sorry Lori or Mark Cuban
and so I was really excited about it and
so I really did want to work with her
and it was a good deal so I actually sat
on the show because you're supposed to
negotiate I said because it makes a good
TV yes and so I said I know I'm supposed
to negotiate but I want to take this
deal right so I didn't you do have it is
really what you see like you can exit
you can talk about it with your partner
you can call a lifeline or a friend they
may edit that out or whatever else but
you can take a minute to think about it
what's something people don't don't see
or don't realize that is different from
having actually gone through it versus
watching it what's it what's one big I
think people know it's edited I don't
think people realize how long the actual
time filming can be from when you walk
in and walk out to like what they edit
down to five minutes so it varies but
mine was probably an hour and they added
it to seven minutes
some people's have gone on up to two to
three hours some are 15 minutes right
and so I think you know it's edited to a
degree but I don't think you realize how
much discussion actually happens with
money she has investing her own money it
is in a fun structure but it's her
capital you know I don't know I will say
she is a prolific salesperson in the
sense that like the top three or four
companies from shark tank and I mean
companies that have done like a quarter
of a billion in sales squatty potty yeah
those she has a relationship with each
of those companies and is invested in
each of those companies so I suspect
quite a bit not to mention her own
patent portfolio and the success she's
like with products there's not an exit
yeah so I don't know I don't know I
don't know she takes that Saudi money no
different right so like she does it just
like an any VC deal is different right
she's negotiating a deal with me right
different I don't know what what terms
are you know with the rest of our
companies I do know she has put all of
these companies on the map from scrub
daddy to squatty potty these companies
have incredible consumers she delivers
how she delivers yeah I'm telling you I
think every actually I don't have a but
it doesn't seem I mean it does seem very
popular apparently so
I guess so Everly well question for you
we actually get the test how do you
actually administer this back three
years ago right and it aired the night
before Cyber Monday it was Thanksgiving
weekend
but my poor team they were wonderful
they canceled all their Thanksgivings
this you know a lot of work but um what
we got about thirty times our normal
traffic but we had an interesting
experience we didn't have this
tremendous like huge spike the night of
in terms of purchases but we ended up
doing about a million dollars in sales
which at the time was a tremendously
large number for us in like the four-day
period after right the show so there's
been a little bit of this interesting
thing for us that I haven't heard many
other companies have which is we doubled
like we doubled in that week on a run
rate standpoint and then we continued
doubling the next month and we never had
that decline right but we didn't have
this spike in like the three hour period
that we aired yeah yeah so and we did I
mean we had to I mean at the time we
were not set up for that scale now we
don't even we know we've always been on
stripe not WooCommerce not shopify
bigcommerce we've built on it now and
like totally customized it something
else not I know this is one of the big
ones that actually I think we should
have gone to Shopify but we didn't
gotcha
so I shouldn't know I shouldn't name
them because
right back shout out to Toby Shopify yes
exactly I like to think he's listening
yeah so might be we're trying to get him
on I was gonna say that valuation he
also streams on twitch great guy oh so
yeah so we saw really good traffic
increase but it wasn't it was a very
different pattern and Laurie warned us
about that she said some companies it's
like they sell out immediately and some
companies it's just a slow slow burn so
that was what it was with us but we did
not crash which was essential
[Music]